لا معلومات دقيقه عن عدد الناس الذين
كانوا يسكنون في هذه المباني لكن امامنا
اربع مباني يتالف الواحد منها نحو ارض من
اربعه طوابق وهذه المدينه بشكل عام مكتظه
بالسكان لان النازحين من جميع انحاء سوريا
يقصدونها وهي قريبه من الحدود السوريه
التركيه لذلك يتوقع ان تكون ان يكون عدد
الضحايا كبيره كبيره في الحقيقه في المدن
المدن التي تضررت هي المدن التي تقع بجوار
الحدود السوريه التركيه وكل هذه المدن
مكتظه بالسكان لا يمكن ان تجد مثلا منزلا
فارغا ليس فيه عائله تسكنه لان هذه المدن
اصلا تستوعب اكثر من طاقتها بكثير اي ال
المناطق التي تضررت قلت المناطق القريبه
من الحدود السوريه التركيه مكتظه بالسكان
وكما ان مناطق سيطرت النظام السوري ايضا
طالع لها الكثير من
الدمار والكثير من الاضرار وزاره الصحه
التابعه النظام تعلن عن اكثر من 200 قتيل
هناك محافظه حماه انهار بناء من تسع طوابق
وايضا اسفر عن قتلى وجرحى محافظه حماه
تبعد عن هذه النقطه 130 كيلو متر وبالتالي
فان اثار الهزات الارضيه وصل الى 133
كيلومتر اثناء سيرنا في خط
الاتجاه الحدود السوريه التركيه مررنا على
عده بلدات كانت هناك خسائر لكن كل بلده
وخسائر بسيطه لكن كل بلده مررنا فيها كان
فيها بناء دمر او مبنى طابقي دمر نحن
نتحدث هنا عن اقتضاء السكان سكاني وتغير
ديموغرافي كبير والمدن هنا حدثت فيها يعني
طفره عمرانيه باتجاه
استيعاب النازحين الذين ياتون وبالتالي
فان هذه المدن فان هذه المباني ليست مجهزه
بشكل جيد النازحون يسكنون حتى
التي كانت قد تعرضت للقصف او المباني
العائله للسقوط
والتركيبه السكانيه هنا حقيقه هي
استثنائيه بكل ما تعني الكلمه وبالتالي
فان مثل هذه مثل هذه الكارثه التي حدثت
بالتاكيد سوف يكون لها مضاعفات كبيره على
السكان